when it comes to medical marijuana I
have more of a practical view than
anything else what I'm not going to be
doing is using Justice Department
resources to try to circumvent the state
laws on this issue right now he is the
toughest president that we have I've
ever had on the war on drugs where did
that come from I was thrown on the
ground 11 to 15 cops all pointing their
guns at me scream they almost shot the
dog as a law enforcement official very
happy to see the current
administration's stance on the issue of
medical marijuana the inauguration there
was some raids on California and medical
marijuana dispensary you expect those
sorts of race to continue Obama's
Department of Justice repeatedly vowed
not to use federal resources to go after
medical marijuana in states where it was
legal well what the president said
during the campaign you'll be surprised
to know will be consistent with what
we'll be doing here in law enforcement
but now that same Department is cracking
down in California the law has been
hijacked by profit ears who are
motivated not by compassion but by money
in the following weeks medical marijuana
activists from around the state held
rallies to protest these developments
this surprise attack on the medical
cannabis users in California it's hugely
unfair and unjust it's tyrannical is
what it is cops are not used to losing
or even compromising they got tired of
waiting with having lost more court
cases than they won so they caught it in
their biggest gun they called in the
federal cops
you
you're a liar President Obama you said
that you weren't going to do anything
you said that you were going to let the
state's handle it well then be a man and
stand up and tell the federal government
to go home the Department of Justice
sent letters to dispensaries across the
state reminding them that United States
law takes precedence over state law and
property is subject to seizure and
forfeiture to the United States Erin
Sandusky owns g3 holistic in
California's Inland Empire the
Department of Justice gave him 14 days
to get out I turn white ja the floor it
was unexpected we all want the same
things I we don't want to seek more
crime we want to see less crime that's
why we have these places Sandusky got
into the medical marijuana industry two
years ago after leaving another line of
business behind I was in the mortgage
business for 20 years we were too small
to bail instead of too large to fail to
search out access patients have to go to
some places many of us would never
travel to and I thought that there was a
lot of work there that needed to be done
Sandusky's business sense proved right
and he soonduk spanned adjey's three
into several cities and even opened his
own grow house so that he could control
the quality of his product one of the
big problems and challenges that we've
been facing is one of the allegations of
profiteering a lot of times they don't
get to see what the back side is the
investments that we make not only
cultivation
research and that's not cheap obviously
there's no book that we can follow so a
lot of these things we have to come up
with ourselves that not only is
expensive but it takes a lot effort on a
lot of people's party dispensaries on
their face are any illegal operation
there's no Avenue in the law whatsoever
to accommodate the sales of marijuana
mark Brewster and Glenn Walsh members of
the California narcotic Officers
Association have a big problem with what
Sandusky is doing what the
administration has come out and said is
that they will support a states right to
have medical marijuana however if anyone
in that state is violating that law then
they will judiciously prosecute them I
think that's a very wide stance for them
to take and I look forward to them
exercising their jurisdiction in
California on November first 2011
officer Walsh got his wish the feds
raided all three of g3 stores as well as
the grow house this is the grow room
that I showed you last week this is one
of the grow rooms that we were in after
years of work and hundreds of thousands
of dollars spent this is what was left
of Sandusky's business
but they came in and uh and full raid
guns drawn Wow patients were handcuffed
some of our senior patients were
handcuffed and taken they seized all of
our assets my all of my personal assets
I got sixty dollars in my pocket that's
it I don't I don't have nothing what's
the future hold for you and for g3 I
don't even know officials from the
Department of Justice would not
participate in an on camera interview
but according to the search warrant the
DEA rated Sandusky's three stores as
well as his home and the home of his
colleague because marijuana has a
schedule one controlled substance which
under federal law means that it is not
recognized as having any medical value
and any possession distribution or
cultivation is a violation of federal
law marijuana is not modern medicine and
people will try to say well there need
to be more studies there there has to be
more studies when we look at marijuana
marijuana has been studied and studied
and studied but the American Medical
Association said just the opposite in
2009 urging that marijuana's status is a
federal schedule one controlled
substance be reviewed with the goal of
facilitating the conduct of clinical
research and development of cannabinoid
based medicines if I take the big pharma
medications that they had me on in 2001
I would not have a liver and then I die
I don't get high anymore it just takes
my pain away I was diagnosed with HIV 15
years ago the same year that prop 215
was passed it is helping me to increase
my appetite it gives me the energy to
come here in protest for people that I
know that are sicker than me another
portion of the search warrant reads the
sale for profit of marijuana including
sales inside of marijuana stores may
constitute a violation of California's
medical marijuana laws when we
collectively or cooperatively get
together to cultivate marijuana we can
do that and if it's my land and I would
like to help you cultivate your
marijuana I can do that you cannot
however reimburse me for any expenses we
don't all grow our own lettuce tomatoes
pickles you know we go to the store we
pick those up so and that many of those
patients are too sick to even try so
you've got to be able to trust somebody
to do it for you and that's where we get
the necessity for a club because you
know we put those professionals in place
that know how to do it I don't believe
that that portion of the law involving
reimbursement or financial gain from the
growing of marijuana I don't think
that's a problem at all i think it's a
very good sound basis when you have that
much of the substance that much cash
then you also have the other problems
that come with it and the violence
that's behind that much money in that
business is incredible as you can see
from some of the border violence we have
going on but Sandusky is in fueling the
cartels by importing their product he
grows his own reports his profits pays
his taxes his reward for this diligence
they'll lose energy
so what's the little one behind Wow as
well I mean I'm what are they gonna do
to me thrown in jail yes and yet as the
feds step up enforcement against medical
marijuana a growing portion of the
population is beginning to lean towards
all out legalization I was original one
of the original drug wires when Nixon
announced the war on drugs I let the
narcotic enforcement ever occur the city
of Los Angeles in those years and since
that time I have come to see the damage
that prohibition has done to our country
and our communities and especially our
young people make it legal in charge
taxes on it instead of putting the money
in the pockets of the real criminals the
Mexican cartels don't get me wrong the
cartels are bad but the drugs are worse
the cartels just send drugs here and yes
they kill everybody to make sure that is
done the drugs are what's destroying our
society an appeals court told Sandusky
and others to keep their doors shut in a
ruling just days after the raid the
court held that individual cities are
allowed to ban dispensaries even if they
are allowed to exist under state law
since the October announcement from the
Department of Justice the federal
government has issued letters
threatening to shut down dozens of
dispensaries across California as a
younger man I was definitely carpe diem
seize the day and in my heart I am a
libertarian now that I'm a parent I'm
more about carpet hits and when I look
at especially as a law enforcement
officer the decisions that I make must
protect and promote my society when we
look at marijuana in the legalization of
that there is no one that can tell you
legalizing marijuana is going to protect
or promote our society on any angle on
any ground on anything that they want to
say unless you want to talk about
libertarian rights unless we want to
talk about the freedom of an individual